hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to happy game it's been
a while
beautiful
and uh
okay i think this is just an indication
of where i was
and i don't remember that thing i
remember that thing pulling me down okay
well here we are hey
back at it again with another fun
adventure in happy game land uh hi
how are you you good okay uh
wow um great sorry for everything that i
did before
with all the you know
feeding you to stuff but you know you
also
i'm sorry what happened what just oh
am i looking inside that thing
oh gross
[Music]
is it getting
clearer oh
there we go
weird oh
oh
okay
hi
what's uh wrong with you
oh
[Music]
okay
the color seems to be going away
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well this is terrible okay well oh my
god this tryptophobia is so bad i'm just
gonna make a quick hey
yo
oh hi
you're not what i thought you were but
hey you got a little oh
it's turning green a bit
oh wow
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay i see
oh boy
oh this is great
oh boy
[Music]
oh
my god
[Music]
okay well that one got caught in the
blast so you know that's a little good i
guess
um
great
this game man this game is so nuts it's
so nuts
it's so much of nuts
hey how you doing there pal oh
what is that i'll take that thank you
get off of that yeah
i don't know what that is but it's mine
now
candy matches oh
that seems irresponsible of me but oh
whatever
oh hi
how are you
oh
god
okay
[Music]
well you know we're only a little bit
into this game and i already feel
terrible about my actions uh wham
[Music]
let's pop another one on there
all right yeah yeah
all right
make room make room gang make room
[Music]
oh
okay
hi
how you pal
oh you shy you don't want me to touch
your heart you don't want me to make
explode i i guess that makes sense
that makes perfect
sense you know what'll happen
oh something happened i was doing
something
oh oh
[Music]
uh
okay
okay um
oh boy
okay and uh kaboom
how are you doing this kid
kid how are you doing this oh one of
them caught it good
one of them caught it
[Music]
all right cool it must be the hearts of
those things or whatever however that
makes sense
all right i see one more over here i
wonder if i'm gonna be able to get to it
lovely
lovely place what happens where
all right fine man well get a load of
this
you're gonna love this
oh wow look at you hey
what are you doing there
oh
god no
oh god no
oh oh it's fine
oh it's not fine it's not fun it's not
fine
[Music]
i don't know how you can see this gets
on the other side but whatever
okay
well that don't look do good i probably
should have kept that around wait where
to go
okay maybe it's not that i have to put
the one in oh interesting
oh interesting
oh god there you go okay
so it's something about
opening this up as it's happening
i can't put more than one in so i
this is just what has to happen so it's
open oh hey hi friend
okay what happens if i do this
okay no he just went back in that's all
that happened
okay now what if i put a rabbit in
and leave a rabbit in charge
okay now you can't escape
and you're gonna be
done up by this bunny
okay that makes sense
i mean it don't make sense but you know
it is what it is
oh my god what is that
oh my god
oh my god
oh okay well there's the heart
great stuff great stuff
feeling very confident about all my
decisions
[Music]
you guys really shouldn't leave all your
hearts lying around kind of bad for your
long-term health
[Music]
all right kaboom well you're in pieces
now and i get my bunny back definitely
everything is right with the world and i
am all good
oh smile
[Music]
yep just as i suspected not everything
is right with the world
what are you controlling now with your
nervous system
gross how
well
ball was life and then bunny was life
and now i guess i'm gonna have one more
part of my life
oh
oh this is fun
wake up
your style's a little different
[Music]
puppy
oh no are you gonna keep puppy away from
me no puppy
puppy please
hope he'd be good
well go man go
oh yeah here we go it is gonna be puppy
you better not do anything to that puppy
if you do something to that puppy i'm
gonna be so mad i'm gonna crawl into the
video
video game space and i'm going to murray
okay that's fine
oh you better not do anything to that
dog
i swear
i swear
oh i'm making the clouds move
oh
am i doing something
all right
i've done as much as i possibly could i
don't know what that did whoa
oh
my god if you do anything to that dog
i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna murder you
i'm gonna murder you
i'm gonna murder you come on oh
right there
take some of that
and one of these
hi
i see you
dialing it in
dialing it in
that
oh hi that's creepy
you hurt my dog therefore i'm going to
hurt you
these
swords hey
you know how you're a douchebag
oh god what is that
what is that
try me [ __ ]
i'll punch you i'll fight you i don't
care i don't care how many friends you
have i'll destroy you
uh
okay
uh-huh
am i supposed to be intimidated a nice
tooth that's mine thank you
thank you i have other worldly powers
even though i am a child you have no
chance against me i blew up multiple
smiley faces
i got no concern for you you stay there
and think about what you've done
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
you suck
don't you look at me don't even try
looking
hmm
[Music]
oh look at the hands look at the hand
that's adorable
[Music]
i love that
it's very cool
oh hi
this is gonna be tryptophobic isn't it
okay
oh
interesting
that's different
so
oh
well that's weird oh what's down here
hello
whoa
yeah hop on this is
this is how we do oh hey
that's got to be some kind of a record
size-wise
and we're flying
[Music]
uh hi
okay what is that supposed to be
oh
oh
okay
this is fine
broomsticks are a little weird but all
right
oh uh okay
um
what
ah i see
we've got some kind of locomotion
machine
i see one
two
three
ah
[Music]
what if that's if i go three two one
oh no it won't go anymore that's right
[Music]
i've tangled it up
maybe it can only go forward
oh
[Music]
wow you're pretty good at that although
i think that the bottom legs are moving
faster than new oh well that's because
it's moving on his own now this whole
game is like a fever dream of some kind
that's springing from the imagination of
someone just like
just fascinatingly
[ __ ] up in a way but not really you
know it's
it's just so interesting to see
imagination run wild like this
it's kind of crazy
what's over this way nothing well we're
in a big empty landscape as usual
don't know what this is all about but
okay yeah all right okay boogie into the
forest of
cat tails
[Music]
that better be you goody
that better be you goody
goody that better be you
goody i've got a bad feeling about this
goody i got a bad feeling
that's not goody that's the opposite of
goody that's not goodie
okay
weird cryptid demon
oh
god damn it why is everything gotta be
messing with goody
i'll use my psychic powers
oh okay
well you shouldn't have messed with the
likes of me
[Music]
once again very psychic
hi
okay
[Music]
that didn't seem like the logical next
step to that action but i will take it
because my
my genius expands beyond the mere
constraints of my brain hello
don't mind me
clearly one of you hey what's up bob hey
greg steve
sally
all right oh
where are you going
paul
all right
you guys grabbing some brewskis all
right save one for me
uh
i guess where'd you put my dog i will
murder you
hey belle sir i'm late traffic oh
uh hi
oh okay
huh
that's confusing i thought that was me
okay wow that's pretty
pretty cruel um
i guess
no comment why did they run away from me
if they could devour that boy
i have psychic powers i forgot that is
kind of a thing that i do
gooby
[Music]
come on goofy come on come on come on
gooby come on come on go back
all right fine
who is this stacking puzzle
no
i don't know what it is what's above me
interesting as a place for me to
practice my psychic powers i suppose
physics system is
not agreeable at the moment
easy easy
oh
hi what's going on with you
hi friend
how you feeling you feeling good
ah interesting
maybe it doesn't need that maybe it
needs
one of each
oh yeah
hi
freaking cheshire cat over here
oh that's not so much
oh
wow
oh
yeah i know right the colors are pretty
wicked um
are those rocks gonna come back down
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
goody
goody come back the forest is not a good
place to be going into right now
you might want to give it a little bit
the music is funky weird
super weird
all right oh hi oh
oh
puppy oh god no
probably stuck in the backwards upside
down
the book upside down oh puppy come back
here
[Music]
puppy please can i do anything with you
no
papi come back i mean go forward
run forward you'll come back to me
but don't run forward towards me run
away from me
please
oh
oh what the hell wait what does that
mean whoa
hi okay slappy hand
oh weird
oh great
okay
oh damn it missed my chance hi hey
you're so cute they're like dr seuss
hands you know
gotcha
ah
i do have psychic powers okay hi
uh
oh my god
hey what's up i see you saw me waving
uh i'll take this from you thank you
my powers are literally undeniable
you'll take this into you oh
that's weird
why
okay
oh
boy
uh
it's like pulling nose hairs you know
these are just the boogies left at the
end of them
all right um
one more
says fling this around a bit and
out of here all right now you got it
here take this
oh there you go pal you're welcome
you are well goodbye
oh thank goodness these were
here uh
oh hippity
oh catbear move
yep good thing i don't have hair i'm one
punch man strong
doobie
goody
oh hello
what have we here
oh this bunch of lights in the darkness
okay this is normal
oh yeah just coalesce
i like when things just coalesce when i
arrive
oh hey
you a boulder
mind if i poke
come on if i possibly explode your brain
or climb on top that's only the three
actions that i know how to do so uh
oh that's not up i wanted to go up
i seem to be missing something hello
uh is this what i needed
no
okay
interesting
oh you're a bigen
hi
oh that is what i need
interesting
ah so you don't want to share huh
interesting
so they just fall apart
but only in the shadow realm
okay
i have this now
so what can i do with this
oh we got something we got something
going on here
whoa there we go wow ah i see
[Music]
was that good or did you hate it i can't
tell whoa
was that good or did you hate it i don't
know
whoa
all right eat up buddy
pretty good all right pretty good oh
oh
thanks
boulder you were kind of an [ __ ] i
even asked permission for a lot of
things
all right can you take me up please this
time down all right we go down
oh
again
i don't have a body
what does this do what does this do
hi what does this do
you want this
sure that makes sense
right
okay
uh do you want to eat that
oh
that's an arm and a leg all right good
uh
well that's part of me
[Applause]
[Music]
so if that
goes there then it just gets pooped out
again
but if he eats them
they just get up
[Applause]
interesting
oh
hello again legs
no no no no no no no god damn it
[Applause]
[Music]
ah no more eyeballs from these
why oh
we're gone
oh
i don't understand how that worked out
but uh
okay
okay boulder i'm gonna give you one last
chance to take me
oh
i wanna go oh
oh hello
what is this reminds me of
one of the end cut scenes of the
original doom game seeing the hell in
the background what am i looking at
uh
all right
okay
oh wow
all right great where am i am i not even
a body
i'm just a spirit floating in the
nothingness
oh there i go
i am just a soul in the darkness i'm
sure there's nothing big and scary
standing right behind
what big teeth you might have
what huge penis is probably here
ah there i am
[Music]
uh
i'm guessing i try to escape this prison
this flesh prison
not quite
come on now
come on it's weird
oh
there we go whoa
okay
all right oh interesting
good thing i'm psychic
[Music]
oh
look at that smile all right buddy i'm
gonna give you one last shot at this to
do me right by me
you gotta do
all right cool
oh hi
hello are you related to the person i
gave a face
uh
interesting
ah
oh i oh okay
okay
all right creepy weird um not 100 sure
why or what
oh
gooby
gooby you better get over here
oh
goody goody
uh how about you stay away buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
wow
oh
my goodness oh
[Music]
oh lovely
don't
know there's no need for that
okay uh
[Music]
how long did it take to make all the art
for this
that that's what i think is fascinating
how
there's so much here and it's all so
very like diverse
it's all different it's kind of crazy
[Music]
it's nuts
oh there we go i just had to grab him no
interesting
oh i see what i need to do
it's quite simple
ah i see
[Music]
we go
goodbye
all right and i'm on my way god just
look at all this i know some of it
repeats but just like
throughout the whole game
i'm a little twitchy
how long did it take
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi welcome
good to see you
oh that's my taint
okay that's my entire body
please stop
oh
oh
i don't know why they're blowing up but
they couldn't take the strain
all right well more dead and me alive i
think
i'll just carry on my way
don't like the sperm ones
those are particularly disturbing
gross
oh hi
um
are we gonna fight
okay yeah we're gonna fight
[Music]
all right um
oh
speeding up
okay we're starting the engine the
engine of my psyche the engine of my
brain
did i just rewind everything are we
going to go back to the beginning is
this how this started i don't remember
what the opening scene
[Music]
was what a beautiful little cloud
[Music]
what a beautiful little nightmare
and all this was just one night of bad
dreams
um
i don't trust it
oh oh oh oh
[Music]
what
[Music]
ah i feel happy
happy end
zera unhappy end cause you know how you
said the happy game
i think maybe you know happy ending as
happy as you could want it to be you
know what i mean we'll see what we got
going on here huh that seems to be all
of it but uh
i don't know man
[Music]
i don't know man
what does continue do
yeah i guess it's just the last
checkpoint huh there's nothing else to
do besides this what if i go the other
way no it only goes the one way yeah it
only does the one thing which is rewind
okay exit menu all right
so i think that's the end of happy game
just a fantastically imaginative and
nightmarish experience
what a weird
and lovely experience
just truly something
special that's all i really got to say
about is like special and i don't mean
that in any other way than like this was
really something
incredible just what an experience
so crazy but so cool at the same time
thank you everybody so much for watching
support the developers link to the game
is in the description below
and thanks for watching and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you